hi und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute
live es ist wieder soweit und vielleicht
habt ihr es da draußen auch schon
mitbekommen aktuell findet in Davos in
der Schweiz das Weltwirtschaftsforum
statt und da kommen ganz verschiedene
Menschen aus Politik Wirtschaft und der
Wissenschaft zusammen über die großen
Krisen unserer Zeit zu verhandeln und zu
diskutieren da sind insgesamt mehr als
Regierungschefs vor Ort ja und eins der
Hauptthemen ist natürlich der russische
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine und eine
Frage steht dazu aktuell ganz besonders
im Fokus nämlich wie verhält sich
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz zur Lieferung
von Kampfpanzern in die Ukraine der
Druck auf ihn wächst eigentlich wollte
Scholz Deutschland zur Führungsnation im
europäischen Sicherheitsfragen und im
Sicherheitsnetz machen und jetzt wollen
aber Partner wie Großbritannien und
Polen Kampfpanzer liefern und warten auf
grünes Licht von Scholz gibt Scholz
jetzt in Davos nach das werden wir sehen
wie übertragen gleich live die Rede des
Kanzlers aus Davos hierbei ZDF heute
live und wir wollen natürlich auch
darüber sprechen was wir da gehört haben
und das nicht alleine sondern gemeinsam
mit meinem zdf-kollegen Ulf Röller der
ist Korrespondent vor Ort in Davos und
mit der Osteuropa und Außenpolitik
Expertin Sarah pagung von der
körperstiftung und wie immer möchte ich
dazu natürlich auch eure Fragen und
Anregungen und Kommentare einsammeln
wenn ihr also was zum Thema mit uns
teilen wollt dann macht das gerne hier
direkt im Youtube Chat oder per Mail an
ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de und ich würde sagen
jetzt gucken wir mal direkt in die
Schweiz nach Davos zu ultra hallo
hallo ich grüße oder wie man hier sagt
Grüze
in die Schweiz ja ich glaube wir können
uns alle vorstellen es gibt aktuell
total viele Krisen in Davos die
besprochen werden wie nehmen sie denn
die Stimmung vor Ort aktuell war
also ist doch eine große
Nachdenklichkeit Davos gilt ja als ein
Forum der mächtigen der Wohlhaben der
großen Eliten die diese Welt wirklich
mitbestimmen sie haben das angesprochen
mehr als 50 Regierungschefs sind hier
sie sind wirklich die Menschen die über
das Schicksal der Erde mitbestimmen und
das eigentlich auch gestalten insofern
ist man doch auch ein bisschen
enttäuscht und selbstkritisch weil es so
viele Krisen wie es zur Zeit gibt
eigentlich in der letzten 20 30 40
Jahren nicht gegeben hat wir haben also
die bekannte Klimakrise wir haben durch
den Ukraine Krieg eine Energiekrise wir
haben eine Wirtschaftskrise und wir
haben auch eine politische Krise und es
gibt die große Angst hier in Davos dass
diese Krisen sich zu einer wie man hier
sagt monsterkrise entwickeln und dann
wirklich die Welt in ein Ungleichgewicht
bringen also sie ist sehr viel
Selbstkritik weil die Eliten eben nicht
das liefern was sie versprechen nämlich
eine Welt der ist besser geht
ja eine der wichtigen Krisen auf jeden
Fall der russische Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine und ich habe am Anfang schon so
ein bisschen angedeutet dass
Bundeskanzler Scholz der aktuell unter
Druck steht warum das so ist das hat
sich Ines Trams mal für uns angeguckt
Olaf Scholz will dass Deutschland in
Europa eine Führungsrolle einnimmt das
ist ein Anspruch Deutschland strebe
danach ein Garant europäischer
Sicherheit zu werden so wie es unsere
Verbündeten von uns erwarten doch in der
Realität sieht das anders aus bloß kein
Alleingang so bisher die Begründung des
Kanzlers warum Deutschland keine
Kampfpanzer Leopard in die Ukraine
liefert während er zögert den
europäische Partner voran so will der
britische Premier Sonic die Ukraine
stärker unterstützen einschließlich der
Bereitstellung von Challenger 2 Panzern
der polnische Präsident du da prescht
ebenfalls vor wir werden eine Kompanie
von Leopard Panzern im Rahmen einer
Koalition übergeben die sich derzeit
bildet mit dabei auch Finnlands
Präsident ninese bei einem europäischen
Vorgehen wird auch ein Beitrag Finnlands
benötigt der Eindruck von außen der
entsteht ist immer dass Deutschland
gedrängt wird etwas zu tun und eben
nicht freiwillig den nächsten Schritt
geht und das immer erst dann macht wenn
sich andere auch bewegt haben und eben
nicht sich an die Spitze einer Bewegung
setzt und andere Staaten mitnimmt so war
es auch bei der Entscheidung
Schützenpanzer Marder der Ukraine zu
liefern erst als der Druck der
Verbündeten zu groß wurde handelte
Scholz kein agierender sondern ein
Getriebener das entspricht leider nicht
dem selbstgenannten Führungsanspruch der
Bundesregierung hier scheitert die
Regierung Scholz und das ist hoch bitter
weil das Vertrauen in die Bundesrepublik
zunehmend singt doch der Kanzler zögert
kein Jahr zu kampfpanzerlieferungen
zumindest bis heute
ja wir sehen da gibt es auf jeden Fall
nur Uneinigkeit Herr Roller erwarten sie
denn dass diese Frage der
panzerlieferung jetzt in den nächsten
Tagen in Davos geklärt wird
also ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht
dass diese Frage in Davos geklärt wird
ich bin mir auch nicht sicher wie weit
die Rede die nun in wenigen Minuten von
Olaf Scholz anfängt die auf dem Forum
und man kann sagen dass das ein
Highlight ist hinter mir fühlt sich
immer mehr der Saal das kann man nicht
ganz sehen weil das etwas unten aber da
ist wirklich das die Top-Veranstaltung
aber ich glaube nicht dass Olaf Scholz
ein klaren Plan entwickeln wird wie das
mit der panzerfrage weitergeht aber ich
glaube wir haben ja auch am Freitag das
sogenannte Randstein Format muss man
erklären was das ist das ist innerhalb
der NATO die Verteidigungsminister die
sich speziell mit der Ukraine
beschäftigen und dort könnte es dann
klarer Hinweise geben ob es
Panzerlieferungen gibt Deutschland in
dieser Frage bewegt das Wort fallen wir
schalten direkt einmal rüber weil die
redet für stolz beginnt vielen Dank
sehr geehrter Herr Professor Schwab
lieber Klaus sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
what's a difference year makes also ich
vor einem Jahr zu ihnen sprach da
drehten sich unsere Diskussionen um den
Weg der Weltwirtschaft aus der Pandemie
am Anfang des Jahres 2022 haben viele
mit einem Boom gerechnet oder zumindest
mit einem kräftigen Rückenwind für die
Transformation unserer Volkswirtschaften
hinter Klimaneutralität dann kam der 24
Februar
seitdem führt Russland einen
imperialistischen Angriffskrieg hier bei
uns in Europa
ein Krieg mit furchtbaren Konsequenzen
vor allem für die Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine
wurde bekannt dass der
Staatssekretär des Innenministers und 15
weitere Opfer in einem tragischen
helikopterunfall ums Leben kommen wir
denken an ihre Familien
aber die Folgen des Krieges treffen auch
uns
Energie kostet zwischenzeitlich so viel
wie nie zuvor
auf der ganzen Welt sind die
Produktionskosten und Verbraucherpreise
durch die Decke gegangen
viele fürchten eine dauerhafte weltweite
Renaissance von Kohle und Öl
dieser Fall eintritt dann wäre das ein
Komma fünf Grad Ziel bedeutungslos
unsere Lieferketten müssen an neue
geopolitische Realitäten angepasst
werden
Realitäten die sie lieber Klaus gestern
Magie patchwork of powers bezeichnet
haben und überall dem hängt das
Damoklesschwert einer neuen
Fragmentierung der Welt die Gefahr von
de-globalisierung und dkplänen
und doch meine Damen und Herren ist das
nur ein Teil der Geschichte des
vergangenen Jahres nur ein Teil der
Realität mit der wir uns hier in Davos
beschäftigen
der andere Teil sieht wie folgt aus
Russland ist mit seinen
imperialistischen Kriegszielen schon
jetzt vollkommen gescheitert die Ukraine
verteidigt sich mit großen Erfolg und
beeindruckende Mut eine breite
internationale Allianz allen voran die
G7 unterstützt das Land dabei
wirtschaftlich finanziell humanitär und
militärisch Deutschland allein hat im
vergangenen Jahr über 12 Milliarden Euro
gegeben und wir werden die Ukraine
weiter unterstützen solange wie es
wichtig ist
in Berlin in Berlin at the end of
Oktober Ende Oktober haben wir in Berlin
zusammen mit internationalen Expertinnen
und Experten einen Marshallplan für den
langfristigen Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
entworfen eine Plattform der wichtigsten
Geber koordiniert den Prozess und sorgt
in Abstimmung mit der Ukraine für die
Umsetzung eben dieses Plans
Kapital wird dabei eine zentrale Rolle
spielen
ich weiß von vielen deutschen
Unternehmen dass sie die Chancen eines
ukrainischen Wirtschaftswunders
ergreifen wollen
insbesondere wenn sich das Land nach
Kriegsende aufmacht in die Europäische
Union
doch damit der Krieg endet muss
Russlands Aggression scheitern
deshalb liefern wir ein Abstimmung mit
unseren Partnern der Ukraine
kontinuierlich Waffen in dem Umfang des
inclus darunter auch
flugwehrabwehrsysteme wie IRST oder
Patriot
Artilleriegeschütze oder auch
Schützenpanzer das ist Teil einer
tiefgreifenden Zeitenwende in der
deutschen außen und Sicherheitspolitik
und noch etwas gehört zur Geschichte des
vergangenen Jahres
Deutschland hat sich innerhalb weniger
Monate vollständig unabhängig gemacht
von russischen Gas russischem Öl und
russischer Kohle wir haben neue
Partnerschaften geschlossen in Asien
Afrika oder Amerika und damit
Abhängigkeiten verringert
und so kann ich sagen unsere
Energieversorgung in diesem Winter ist
gesichert danke
Speicher danke mehr
energieeffizienzwerten Solidarität
innerhalb Europas und dank der
Bereitschaft unserer Unternehmen und von
Millionen Bürgerinnen und Bürger Energie
einzusparen
unsere Entlastungsmaßnahmen für
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und für die
Unternehmen wirken
die Inflation geht langsam zurück
übrigens auch dank den Schritten der
Zentralbanken
die industrielle Produktion in
Deutschland ist in den vergangenen
Monaten stabil geblieben trotz aller
Widrigkeiten die Zahl der Beschäftigten
liegt auf Rekordniveau und hat zuletzt
weiter zugelegt vor allem aber die
Transformation hin zu einer
klimaneutralen Wirtschaft diese zentrale
zukunftsausgabe unseres Jahrhunderts
erfährt gerade eine völlig neue Dynamik
nicht trotz sondern wegen des russischen
Kriegs und des veränderungsdrucks der
damit für uns Europäerinnen und Europäer
einhergeht
egal ob wirtschaftslenkerin oder
klimaaktivieren ob Sicherheitspolitiker
oder Investoren
inzwischen ist für jede und jeden von
uns glasklar erkennbar dass die Zukunft
allein denn erneuerbaren Energien gehört
aus Kostengründen aus Umweltgründen aus
Sicherheitsgründen und weil sie auf
Dauer die bessere Rendite versprechen
und deshalb ja das zurückliegende Jahr
hat Grundlegendes geändert für
Deutschland und Europa
aber auch Deutschland hat sich
grundlegend verändert
wir nehmen die dekarbonisierung unserer
Industrie entschlossen in Angriff wir
wollen bis 2045 klimaneutral werden und
gleichzeitig ein starkes Industrieland
bleiben
gezeigt das kann und das wird auch
gelingen
nicht einmal sieben Monaten haben wir in
Deutschland eine völlig neue import-
auch für Wasserstoff
konnte ich das zweite flüssiggast
Terminal innerhalb von weniger Wochen
einweihen und zwar in ludwin
übermorgen rechnen wir mit einem neuen
Terminal Schiff im Hafen von Brunsbüttel
und weitere werden folgen
das ist nicht nur eine gute Nachricht
für die Energiesicherheit Deutschlands
und unserer europäischen Nachbarn die
wir über diese Terminals mitversorgen es
zeigt vor allem eins Deutschland kann
beweglich kann unbürokratisch kann
schnell sein
diese neue deutschland-geschwindigkeit
machen wir zum Maßstab
das ist unser künftiges Anliegen auch
bei der Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft insgesamt
daran können ihre Unternehmen uns messen
gibt jetzt vor dass der Ausbau von
Windkraft von Solarenergie von Strom und
wasserstoffnetzwerk jetzt vorrangig
ausgebaut werden wird
allein zwei Prozent unserer Landesfläche
werden wir für die Windenergie
bereitstellen und zwar unbürokratisch
wir haben die Prozesse so verschlankt
dass die Genehmigungen für Stromnetze um
nur ein Beispiel zu nennen jetzt im
Schnitt zwei Jahre schneller erfolgen
und wir werden noch ein Tempo zulegen
auch auf unsere Ausbauziele können Sie
sich verlassen die Blockaden sind
weggefegt
für 2023 haben wir allein den Umfang der
Ausschreibungen für Windparks an Land
mehr als verdoppelt
2013 verdoppelt sich auch der Anteil
erneuerbarer Energien an der
Stromerzeugung
nimmt unser Strombedarf zu von heute 600
auf 750 Terawattstunden bis zum Ende des
Jahrzehnts
und in den 2030er Jahren erwarten wir
einen nochmalige Verdoppelung des
Bedarfs das ist ein gewaltiger Anstieg
die Bundesnetzagentur hat deshalb einen
klaren Auftrag bekommen unsere
Stromnetze jetzt darauf vorzubereiten
und auszubauen die Fortschritte werden
wir regelmäßig überprüfen liegen wir
unter dem soll wird nachgesteuert
elektricity alone ist Elektrizität
alleine reicht aber nicht aus für den
Industriestandort Deutschland ich denke
zum Beispiel auch an die Stahlindustrie
hier wird Wasserstoff eine entscheidende
Rolle spielen
und das ist längst keine Zukunftsmusik
mehr
thyssenKrupp hat im Herbst den
Startschuss gegeben für den Bau einer
direktreduktionsanlage zur Produktion
von CO2 Armen premiumstahl bei einer
Produktion von 2,5 Millionen Tonnen
spart diese Anlage pro Jahr 3,5
Millionen Tonnen CO2
hier zeigt sich die Innovationskraft
Europas
Europa ist doch Platz 1 der
Patentanmeldungen für Wasserstoff und
jede zehnte weltweit stammt aus
Deutschland
in Deutschland entstehen gerade die
ersten Lieferketten für grünen
Wasserstoff
wir nutzen zum Beispiel offshore wind in
der Nordsee für unsere eigene Produktion
parallel schließen wir weltweit
wasserstoffpartnerschaften
solange die Mengen gering und der Preis
für die Herstellung entsprechend hoch
sind sorgt der Staat für einen
lukrativen Preis für die Industrie
unser Ziel ist nicht weniger als ein
Elektrolyse Boom
und mit den wachsenden Mengen einer
wasserstoffgetriebene Industrie die das
Klima schonend und die unabhängige ist
von den volatilen Preisen für fossile
Energie
Energie muss bezahlbar bleiben in
Deutschland in Europa und weltweit
in Deutschland haben wir beschlossen den
Strom und Gaspreis für Bürgerinnen
Bürger und Unternehmen zu deckeln
dies wird bis 2024 gelten
rund 2,2% des Bruttoinlandsprodukts
nehmen wir dafür jährlich in die Hand
insgesamt bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro das
ist kraftvoll und maßvoll zugleich
es bietet ihren Unternehmen verlässliche
Energiepreise und Planungssicherheit für
Investitionen in die Transformation in
Deutschland
in der Europäischen Union haben wir uns
auf gemeinsame gasspeicherziele und
gemeinsame Gas Einsparziele geeignet
wir werden zudem künftig häufiger
gemeinsam Gas einkaufen und die
Einspeicherung besser koordinieren und
wir nutzen unsere Marktmacht damit sich
die europäischen Preise nicht komplett
vom Weltmarkt entkoppeln
übrigens wir sind uns auch unserer
weltweiten Verantwortung bewusst
das sage ich ganz ausdrücklich in
Richtung unserer Freunde und Partner in
Asien Afrika und in Lateinamerika und
der Karibik wenn wir in Europa zu hohen
Preisen auf dem Weltmarkt Flüssiggas
kaufen dann fehlt dieses in anderen
Ländern wir müssen Alternativen finden
für die rund 120 Milliarden Kubikmeter
Gas aus russischen Pipelines die auf dem
Weltmarkt fehlen
mehr erneuerbare Energien werden
gebraucht natürlich aber vorübergehend
auch zusätzliche Gasvorkommen
dass diese mangels bezahlbaren Gases auf
noch klimaschädlich umsteigen
das wäre es besonders schädlich für die
Umwelt
dabei müssen wir neue Logins neue Pfad
Abhängigkeiten unbedingt vermeiden indem
wir bei neuen Projekten von Beginn an
Wasserstoff mitdenken und parallel den
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
forcieren
kurzfristig gehen damit womöglich etwas
höhere Kosten einher
langfristig aber sparen wir alle
denn langfristig werden die Folgen des
Klimawandels so weniger dramatisch
ausfallen
auch in Deutschland verlangt die
Umstellung auf eine klimafreundliche
Wirtschaft große Anstrengungen
wir sprechen jetzt von rund 400
Milliarden Euro für den Ausbau
erneuerbarer Energien
es sind Investitionen die übrigens
längst stattfinden
das jüngste Beispiel dafür ist der
Milliardenauftrag für Siemens Energy um
einen neuen Offshore Windpark ans
Stromnetz anzuschließen es ist nur ein
Beispiel das zeigt warum diese
zeitenwände hin zu einer
klimafreundlichen Industrie auch nicht
das Ende unserer Industrie sein wird
sondern ein neuer Anfang
immerhin hat das deutsche
Wirtschaftsmodell auch vor der
Energiekrise die Russland ausgelöst hat
nicht alleine auf den energieintensiven
Massenproduktionen von Aluminium Zement
oder Rohstahl beruht sondern auch auf
Forschungs-
hören in der Welt
und dennoch war und ist Deutschland
wettbewerbsfähig das liegt an den
tausenden kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen im ganzen Land
Unternehmen die hoch innovativ sind die
anpassungsfähig sind und gerade deshalb
oft Weltmarktführer sind
das hängt mit den hohen staatlichen und
privaten Investitionen in Forschung und
Entwicklung zusammen wie zum Beispiel
dafür gesorgt haben dass der erste
corona-test und der erste sichere und
wirksame Corona Impfstoff in Deutschland
entwickelt worden
erst im Dezember hat ein Team des
helmholtz-zentrums in Berlin einen neuen
effizienz-weltrekord bei Solarzellen
aufgestellt und schon jetzt wenige
Wochen später bauen unsere Unternehmen
pilotlinien für den Einsatz dieser
Tandem Zelle auf das meine Damen und
Herren ist und bleibt das deutsche
business model gerade auch auf dem Weg
in eine klimaneutrale Zukunft
wo sonst gibt es ein solch breites
Einvernehmen zwischen Unternehmen
ArbeitnehmerInnen Arbeitnehmern und
Politik dass der Weg in die
Klimaneutralität nicht nur ökologisch
notwendig ist sondern unserem Land auch
neue Wettbewerbschancen bietet
bei der aus- und Weiterbildung von
Beschäftigten zum Beispiel Arbeiten
Politik Wirtschaft und Gewerkschaften in
Deutschland eng zusammen
und noch in diesem Land geben wir in
diesem Jahr geben wir in unserem Land
endlich ein modernes Einwanderungsrecht
denn wenn wir als Industrieland
wettbewerbsfähig bleiben wollen brauchen
wir Praktika mit der Erfahrung
qualifizierte Ingenieurinnen Handwerker
und Maschinenbauer
bei uns mit anpacken will der ist uns
willkommen so lautet die Botschaft
für Jahrzehnte haben es die Prognosen
und vorausgesagt dass die Bevölkerung
schrumpfen wird
bislang ist es anders gekommen
Deutschland hat heute genauso viele
Einwohner und so viele Erwerbstätige wie
nie zuvor
und genau diese Entwicklung werden wir
fortschreiben
meine Damen und Herren eine
klimaneutrale Zukunft erreichen wir
natürlich nicht immer Eingang kein Land
kann das
deswegen sind unsere Austausch und ein
Forum wie Davos auch so wichtig
was wir in Deutschland tun dienten Ziel
Europa zum ersten klimaneutralen
Kontinent zur Welt der Welt zu machen
das soll bis 2050 gelingen auf
europäischer Ebene werden wir unsere
netto Treibhausgas Emissionen bis 2030
und mindestens 55 Prozent gegenüber 1990
denken das gilt
wir setzen dabei auf den Markt auf
Wettbewerb und Innovationen
damit steht das Emissionshandelssystem
der EU
für jeden planbar die zulässigen
Emissionsmengen und zugleich wirkt
dieses System als
innovationsbeschleuniger
damit aber die ambitioniertesten nicht
bestraft werden
kommen wir um einen co2-grenzausgleich
in Europa nicht herum
zugleich aber bleibt Europa offen für
internationalen Handel ich setze mich
mit aller Kraft dafür ein dass den
erfolgreich verhandelten
Freihandelsabkommen mit Kanada Korea
Japan Neuseeland und Chile bald weitere
ambitionierte Freihandelsabkommen Folgen
werden mit dem Merkur Indien und
Indonesien
wir möchten auch Verhandlungen für den
Industriesektor mit den Vereinigten
Staaten ermöglichen
auch so schaffen wir einen level playing
field und verhindern dass
emissionsintensive Industrien in Staaten
mit weniger ambitionierten Klimazielen
abwandeln
auf die international climate Club
belong dient übrigens auch der
internationale klimaklub den wir unter
deutscher g7-präsidentschaft beschlossen
haben mit der Einrichtung eines
Sekretariats bei der OECD und der
Internationalen Energieagentur ist der
ab diesem Jahr offen für neue
ambitionierte Mitglieder
in den USA hat diese Ambition einen
Namen
Inflation reduction
Action
die kommenden zehn Jahre sind darin rund
370 Milliarden Dollar für Energie-
und diese Investition begrüße ich ganz
ausdrücklich
auch im deutschen Klima und
transformationsfonds stehen für die
Jahre von
2023 bis 2026 Mittel von fast 180
Milliarden Euro bereit
Regeln zum local content bestimmter
Produkte aber dürfen europäische
Unternehmer nicht diskriminieren
Protektionismus verhinderten Wettbewerb
und Innovationen und schadet dem
Klimaschutz
darüber sprechen wir als die EU mit
unseren amerikanischen Freunden
und zugleich schauen wir was wir selbst
tun können um
Investitionsbedingungen hier in Europa
noch weiter zu verbessern
zum Beispiel dem verdanken wir jetzt
schon einen Neustart der Chipherstellung
in Europa gerade in Deutschland werden
für viele Milliarden mehrere neue
Produktionsstandorte geschaffen die
übrigens auf einer existierenden
Halbleiterindustrie aufbauen können
auch ein Modell für andere
Schlüsseltechnologien sein besonders im
digital- und Klimabereich und die Mittel
dafür stehen bereit
auf
700 Milliarden Euro das europäischen
aufbaufonds sind erst 20% ausgezahlt
seine volle Kraft wird er also noch in
den kommenden Jahren entfalten
um wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben werden
wir zudem das europäische Beihilferecht
noch agiler und flexibler machen so wie
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen es hier gestern vorgeschlagen und
erneut bekräftigt hat
support to expect and don't have können
Investoren von vorhin herein wissen mit
welcher Unterstützung Sie rechnen können
und nicht das Jahre nach einer
Investition meine Damen und Herren das
vergangene Jahr hat uns gefordert wie
selten zuvor und zugleich haben wir
Dinge verändert und vorangebracht wie
selten zuvor
Deutschland selbst verändert sich
und so viel Prognose sei gewagt
auf dem Jahrestreffen des World Economic
Forum 2045 wird mein Nachfolger oder
meine Nachfolgerin zu Ihnen sprechen er
oder sie wird Deutschland dann als einen
der ersten klimaneutralen
Industriestaaten der Welt präsentieren
die Energieversorgung Deutschlands und
Europas wird dann fast ausschließlich
aus grüner Elektrizität Wärme und
Wasserstoff stammen auf unseren Straßen
und Schienen werden wir uns abgasfrei
bewegen unsere Gebäude werden
energieeffizient sein unsere Unternehmen
werden klimaneutral produzieren und zwar
werden unsere Unternehmen die
Technologien die diese Transformation
ermöglicht haben und es weiter
vorantreiben
wenn sie mich also fragen wie und wo sie
nachhaltig und rentabel in die Zukunft
investieren können dann sage ich Ihnen
heute don't look any förder kommen Sie
zu uns nach Deutschland und nach Europa
schönen Dank
[Applaus]
herzlichen Dank Herr Bundeskanzler wir
haben noch einige Fragen aus dem
Publikum wir haben auch ein saalmikrofon
ich möchte nur ein vorweg schicken ich
freue mich auch darauf für die
nachfolgenden Jahre mit ihrem Nachfolge
ja Nachfolgerinnen zu moderieren
Bundeskanzler eine Frage dazu wie
positioniert sich Deutschland in diesen
wie Sie sagten patchwork of power
zunächst einmal würde ich folgendes
sagen wir leben ja in einer Multi
polaren Welt
vielleicht schon seit 20 30 Jahren aber
das werden wir immer besser
nachvollziehen können in den kommenden
Jahren es wird keine bipolare Welt geben
mit ein oder zwei großen Nationen die
große Herausforderung für uns ist
sicherzustellen dass wir eine Welt haben
nicht nur mit verschiedenen starken
Mächten sondern dass wir eine Welt
schaffen die beherrscht wird von
Kooperation von Multilateralismus und da
spielt auch die Politik mit ein
hoffentlich haben wir dieses Jahr damit
begonnen in diese Richtung zu gehen ich
habe beim G7 Gipfel
Demokratien in der Indonesien südaf
Südafrika
Senegal
eingeladen wir hatten auch Sprecher aus
Lateinamerika aus Karibik wir hatten sie
also eingeladen nach Elmar nach
Deutschland zum G7 Gipfel
und damit wollten wir bewusst einen
Dialog auf Augenhöhe einleiten wir
wollten ihnen verständlich machen dass
diese Länder wichtig sind und dass sie
mit anderen Nationen auch mit uns
zusammenarbeiten und Deutschland
zerplatz in dieser Welt besteht darin
diesen Prozess zu unterstützen sehr hart
daran zu arbeiten diese zusammenarbeitet
zwischen
Lateinamerika Afrika an Asien der Europa
Vereinigten Staaten Nordamerika die zum
Erfolg zu verhelfen aber wir müssen auch
verstehen uns dieses nur gelingen wird
wenn wir Teil der Europäischen Union
sind
mit einer geopolitischen und souveränen
Europäischen Union die eine sehr starke
Rolle in der Welt spielen wird
herzlichen Dank dafür Herr Bundeskanzler
vielleicht ein zwei Fragen drei Fragen
aus dem Saal
vielleicht können Sie sich kurz
vorstellen
ich komme aus dem Iran
also genau dies wie Sie wissen ist es so
dass iranische Frauen bedroht werden
getötet werden weil sie friedlich
demonstrieren auf der Straße für
Freiheit für Demokratie diese
revolutionary Guards wir hatten dafür
eingesetzte ich bin auch ein Zielscheibe
gewesen seine vier Menschen waren wir da
damit beauftragt worden mich zu kitten
Neffen also es ist auch Ukraine
unschuldige Ukraine werden von Putin
angegriffen
warum
stufte Deutschland nicht diese
revolutionärsgabe als Terrorismus
Organisation eine wieder zur schon vor
einigen Jahren anders wo der Fall war
vielleicht eine zweite Frage bevor wir
antworten dankeschön
ich repräsentiere
Jordanien es war sehr inspirierend auch
die Rolle Deutschlands im Klinik beim
Klimawandel Übergang zu euer euren
erneuerbaren Energien wir haben einige
Lösungen die sehr leicht zu erreichen
sind wir haben eine nationale Energie
Gesetze auf die Wege gebracht hatte aber
ich möchte noch mal die Rolle der Jugend
da ansprechen welche Kompetenzen meinen
sie werden gebrauchte für die junge
Generation damit sie in der Lage sind
auch im Energie
Sektor eine Führer Führungsrolle zu
übernehmen
vielleicht noch eine letzte Frage bevor
wir dann Herrn Bundeskanzler Antworten
müssen wir Somalia aus der Ukraine Herr
Bundeskanzler vielen herzlichen Dank für
ihre Unterstützung zu Verteidigung
meines Landes es ist nur eine Frage der
Zeit dass auch die schweren Geschütze
und Panzer zu uns gelieferte werden ich
glaube das ist nur eine Frage der
Zeitung also wir hoffen dass sie heute
auch diese letztendliche Entscheidung
dafür treffen sie und die westlichen
alliierte sind dazu bereit und in
Deutschland war der letzte helmshow und
ich möchte gerne dass sie sich dazu
äußern
ja danke schön für diese drei Fragen und
ich möchte auch auf alle drei eingehen
zunächst einmal wir unterstützen die
Menschen in Iran in ihrem Kampf für
Demokratie sehr starke natürlich die
Frauen alle anderen und auch die jungen
Menschen
ganz klar gesagt es ist für alle von uns
sehr wichtig zu verstehen
dass die iranische Regierung die eigenen
Bürger und Bürgerinnen tötete und
deshalb
sind wir auch mit starken Botschaften
dabei mit unseren Freunden in der
Europäischen Union gemeinsam gehen wir
vor mit allen anderen Alliierten um mit
dieser Frage uns auseinandersetzen auch
mit dem Vereinigten Königreich und den
Vereinigten Staaten außerhalb der der
Europäischen Union neue Sanktionen
wurden beschlossen genau wie in der
Vergangenheit und ähm
wir sprechen uns natürlich mit anderen
Affen und neue Sanktionen werden auf den
Weg gebracht und wir werden diese
Situation ganz genau im Auge behalten
und die notwendigen Entscheidungen
treffen
aber es ist wichtig dass wir im
Schulterschluss vorangehen dass wir
gemeinsame Entscheidungen treffen
besonders gilt die Absprache unter den
Ländern der Europäischen Union dann die
Kompetenzen die gebraucht werden
um diese Wende zu bewerkstelligen und um
auch dem Klimawandel Rechnung zu tragen
und das ist eine wichtige Frage die sie
gestellt haben denn wenn wir unsere
Ziele bis Mitte des Jahrhunderts
erreichen wollen dann bleibt uns nicht
viel Zeit
2015 oder in Deutschland 2045 bis dahin
wollen wir die Klimaneutralität erreicht
haben wir wollen eine CO2 neutral sein
das bedeutet die umfangreichste
industrielle Erneuerung die wir seit
wahrscheinlich der das beginnt der
Industrie Revolution 200 Jahren erfahren
das heißt in
Ende des 19 Beginn des 20 Jahrhunderts
diese Zahlen sind ebenfalls zu nennen
das sind Herausforderungen und wir
müssen die notwendigen Technologien
dafür entwickeln wir müssen investieren
Milliarden und Milliarden darin
so dass dieser Fortschritt auch
tatsächlich erreicht wird und das hängt
nicht nur von einem Land an ab
Deutschland kann sich natürlich dafür
einbringen wir sind bereit dazu die
Industrie ist gewillt mitzumachen und
wenn wir weiter so vorgehen dann werden
wir auch es schaffen neue Technologien
zu entwickeln die wir nicht nur selber
benutzen können sondern auch preiswerte
Alternativen bilden für fossile
Brennstoffe mit denen wir heute arbeiten
und in diesem Rahmen ist es so wichtig
dass wir die Länder unterstützen
wir auch Berufsausbildungen fördern um
Ingenieure auszubilden in diesen
Bereichen wo die moderne Technologie
gefragt ist und wir wollen die fördern
die auch diese Kompetenzen erlangen
wollen an den Universitäten das können
wir tun und damit ist auch verbunden die
Unterstützung für andere Länder das ist
ein wichtiger Aspekte ich komme zur
Ukraine wie ich schon in meiner Rede
gesagt habe und ich möchte das noch mal
unterstreichen Deutschland ist eine der
größten Unterstützer des Landes die
Vereinigten Staaten tun vielleicht am
meisten und das ist vielleicht auch gar
nicht so überraschend denn ich glaube
sie haben 800 Milliarden Dollar in ihren
verteidigungs-haushalt investiert ich
glaube das ist so viel oder mehr als
alle europäischen Länder zusammen und
Deutschland hat natürlich eine eigenes
Budget 2%, das
und wir haben eine 500 Milliarden die
wir auch investieren
aber wir haben schon eine früh
entschieden auch eine politische
Änderung anzutreten wir wollen nicht nur
mit militärischer und humanitärer
Unterstützung dabei sein sondern auch im
weiteren Umfeld wir und die in diesem
Fall tun wir das meiste die Vereinigten
Staaten sind auch hier an erster Stelle
wie schon gesagt hat
aber auch für das Vereinigte Königreich
und Deutschland hatte und diese große
Unterstützung wird auch weiter
fortgesetzt werden
in diesem Zusammenhang haben wir
beschlossen dass wir nicht nur Waffen
zur Verfügung stellen die natürlich sehr
effizient ist die Artillerie die
Haubitzen die Panzerhaubitze 2000 z.B
oder die mehrfach Raketen Werfer die
eingesetzt werden sie haben die Ukraine
ihr dabei geholfen sich zu verteidigen
und Sie müssen sich bewusst sein dass
nur die Vereinigten Staaten der die das
vereinigte Königreiche und Deutschland
diese mehrfach Raketenwerfer zur
Verfügung gestellt haben wir liefern
wichtige Waffen die von grundsätzlicher
Bedeutung sind zum Beispiel
die Panzer und auch kleinere Waffen aber
die Iris c-system
um hundertprozentige Zielsicherheit
und das damit können Angriffe aus
Russland abgewehrt werden Angriffe
Häuser auf Einrichtungen auf
Infrastrukturen und so weiter und wir
werden das auch weiterhin tun
das ist der richtige Weg und wir werden
auch die industriekapazitäten ausbauen
um mehr zu liefern in jüngster Zeit
haben wir mit den Vereinigten Staaten
beschlossen und da sind wir auch
arbeiten wir auch in Abstimmung mit
unserem französischen Freunden wir haben
also beschlossen dass wir ähnliche
Waffen liebende Bradley zum Beispiel aus
den Vereinigten von den Vereinigten
Staaten und der Marder Panzer aus
Deutschland und das ist die Strategie
die wir eingeschlagen haben
wir sind strategisch miteinander
verbunden wir arbeiten zusammen mit
unseren Freunden mit unseren Partnern
wir arbeiten mit Ihnen zusammen wir
diskutieren untereinander und wir wollen
nichts im Alleingang tun sondern alles
im Schulterschluss vor allen Dingen mit
den Vereinigten Staaten die eine
herausragende Rolle dabei spielen wenn
es darum geht die Souveränität und die
Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine zu
verteidigen wie ich in meiner Rede schon
sagte wir werden das so lange fortsetzen
wie notwendig
in diesem Zusammenhang möchten wir noch
einmal unterstreichen und bekräftigen
dass sie Ukraine und Ukrainerinnen auf
uns Szenen können und es ist auch ganz
klar dass wir vermeiden möchten dass es
dieser zu einem Krieg zwischen Russland
und der NATO ausartet das ist auch die
Ansicht der Ukraine wie ich aus meinen
vielen Gesprächen mit den
Verantwortlichen herausgehört habe und
deshalb schlagen wir diesen Weg einem
der Wille mein Wille der Wille
Deutschlands und der Wille der
Europäischen Union besteht darin alles
zu tun um die Ukraine darin zu
unterstützen dass sie eine freie
unabhängige Demokratie werden auf dem
Weg in die Europäische Union und das
werden wir weitermachen danke schön Herr
Bundeskanzler damit
beschließen der diesen Teil und
vielleicht können wir
ja so viel zu einer Rede von Olaf Scholz
die in der Rede selbst erstaunlich wenig
zu Ukraine gesagt hat und sehr viel zum
Thema Energie Energiewirtschaft
Energiepolitik aber wir haben ja auf
jeden Fall die letzte Antwort von Olaf
Scholz auf die Ukraine Frage und diese
Dinge möchten wir jetzt diskutieren und
zwar mit euch wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema
habt oder Kommentare und Anmerkungen zu
dieser Rede dann schreibt uns doch gerne
hier im Youtube Chat oder per Mail an
ZDF heute minus live at zdf.de und ich
möchte das natürlich nicht mit euch
alleine diskutieren sondern mit Sarah
pagung von der
körperstiftung so so ist es richtig
hallo
schön dass du bei uns bist Sarah was ist
dein erster Eindruck von dieser Rede
also er hat natürlich also Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat wenig überraschend viel Wert
auf wirtschaftliche Themen gelegt dass
dafür ist natürlich auch das Forum in
Davos des der richtige Ort das richtige
Forum andererseits ist natürlich der
Elefant im Raum die Frage ob in
Deutschland der Lieferung von Leopard 2
Panzern an die Ukraine zu stimmen wird
ob man eben auch selber Panzer liefert
und der Frage ist eher elegant aus dem
Weg gegangen
ja so sehen das eigentlich auch Teile
aus der Community wenn ich immer in die
Kommentare gucke da schreibt zum
Beispiel Viktor Röder auf Youtube er
redet länger über LNG als über die
Ukraine und auch hier im Chat werden die
Forderungen nach einer Zustimmung Scholz
laut hier wird z.B geschrieben
lächerlich dass wir nicht helfen das
sagt krass Steffi auf Facebook andere
Länder machen nicht so rum wollen wir
warten bis Putin vor unserer Tür steht
ja und was ähm verschiedene Partner
Deutschlands zuletzt gefordert haben was
für Forderungen sie direkt dann Kanzler
Scholz stellen das gucken wir uns jetzt
direkt mal an
jemand muss die politische Führung
übernehmen damit die Ukraine unterstützt
wird denn die Kampfpanzer spielen eine
entscheidende strategische Rolle glauben
sie Bundeskanzler Scholz übernimmt diese
Führung ich gehe fest davon aus dass er
einen Entscheidung trifft
ich hoffe dass die Deutschen die die
Panzer ja herstellen mitmachen und sie
liefern
ja das klang jetzt so ein bisschen
anders als dieses schlussstatement von
Kanzler Olaf Scholz der er sagt wir
machen nichts im Alleingang wir machen
alles im Schulterschluss jetzt haben wir
gerade gehört europäische Partner
fordern ihn ganz konkret auf und auch
der dritte Fragesteller auf den sich ja
bezogen hat hat ihn aufgefordert sich
hinsichtlich dieser panzerlieferung in
die Ukraine zu entscheiden Sarah wie
isoliert ist denn Deutschland aktuell in
dieser Position
also ich glaube ich würde das nicht als
isoliert bezeichnen aber auf alle Fälle
als ja vielleicht
Bremsklotz oder zu zögerlich irgendwie
und wir haben jetzt eigentlich seit
Wochen die Situation dass mehrere
deutsche Partner darunter eben ganz
prominant die beiden und die Polen die
Lieferung von nächstes Jahr mal Schützen
im Panzern und dann auch Kampfpanzern an
die Ukraine fordern und Deutschland sich
dort eben sehr zurückhaltend und das
obwohl ja auch die USA durch die Blume
zu verstehen geben dass sie das
eigentlich durchaus befürworten
und das heißt dieser Führungsanspruch
den Bundeskanzler Scholz ja auch selbst
immer wieder formuliert und der
natürlich auch gestellt wird an
Deutschland als ja Wirtschaftsmacht in
Europa auch als politisch zentrales Land
der wird eben nicht erfüllt sondern es
wird eigentlich immer nur darauf
verwiesen dass man sich abstimmen muss
aber alle warten eigentlich schon darauf
dass Deutschland ja sagt und das ist
natürlich oder das erweckt natürlich
einfach einen relativ große Diskrepanz
zwischen dem was gesagt wird und dem was
getan wird
was glaubst du denn was würde das für
eine Stimmung erzeugen im europäischen
Sicherheitsnetz wenn Scholz sich jetzt
z.B entschieden würde die Lieferungen
anderer Partner zu genehmigen aber
selbst nicht zu liefern
also grundsätzlich ist das natürlich
eine Möglichkeit als
Herstellerland muss Deutschland auch die
Lieferung anderer Nationen an die
Ukraine von Leopard 2 Panzern freigeben
wenn das so kommen sollte also ohne eine
eigene deutsche Lieferung birgt das aus
meiner Sicht zwei Probleme das eine ist
das eine konzertierte Lieferung durchaus
sehr große logistische organisatorische
Vorteile bietet weil man eben Panzer
Polen kann und eben nicht nur das
Material selber sondern auch
fragen wie eine entsprechende
Ausstattung wie dann auch im
Kriegsverlauf die Wartung und die
Reparatur und das sind ja durchaus sehr
wichtiger Aspekte und die andere Frage
ist natürlich die politische also wenn
Deutschland hier zwar ja kein also kein
Stopp davor stellt und andere Länder
davon abhält aber selber nicht macht
dann wird natürlich der Unterschied
zwischen Deutschland und den anderen
Ländern einfach noch mal viel deutlicher
und das glaube ich würde ja die Kosten
Bergen dass wir eine weitere deutliche
Verschlechterung Beziehung nicht nur zu
Ukraine selbst haben sondern auch zu den
gerade zu den Mitteln osteuropäischen
Ländern möglicherweise auch zu den USA
und Großbritannien das heißt so eine
Entscheidung hatte möglicherweise
durchaus enorme politische Kosten zu
Folge für die Bundesregierung
ja auch ihr im Chat seit irritiert
teilweise hier kommt einiges an Kritik
an Scholz so schreibt zum Beispiel
Youtube Userin Kelly keine Alleingänge
sagte Scholz dabei ist er ist allein der
die leo-blockade aufrecht erhält und
Scholz du hast es gerade auch schon
angesprochen hat ja selber gesagt er
wolle Deutschland zur Führungsnation im
europäischen Sicherheitsnetz und in
europäischen Sicherheitsfragen machen
sarah ist das etwas was du aus den
Geschehnissen des letzten Jahres
herausliest oder eben nicht viele werfen
ja kannst du das schon zögerlich was
sind für dich ganz konkret die Punkte an
denen man diese Zögerlichkeit ablesen
konnte
also ich glaube da gibt das ganz viele
einzelne Beispiele im letzten Jahren die
man das ganz gut sehen kann also es war
ja zuerst die Neigung Deutschlands noch
vor Kriegsbeginn also vor haben 24
Februar Waffen an die Ukraine zu liefern
obwohl das ja auch durchaus schnelle
Debatte nicht nur Ukraine sondern auch
in anderen europäischen Ländern war dann
gab es nach Kriegsbeginn erstmal eine
Debatte in Deutschland ob es überhaupt
noch Sinn macht an die Ukraine Waffen zu
liefern oder ob das eigentlich nicht
ohnehin schon zu spät ist und keinen und
nichts mehr ändern würde und dann hatten
wir natürlich diese ganzen einzelnen
Debatten um ja defensiv es ist
offensiver schwere Waffen vs leichte
Waffen dann
[Musik]
schützenpanzerbörse
Kampfpanzer und man hat überall
eigentlich das Gefühl dass immer eine
Art neue Hürde oder Grenze von der
Bundesregierung aufgebaut wird über die
man dann Monate braucht und über die
hinüber zu kommen und das ist natürlich
von der Kommunikation ich würde sagen
sehr ungünstig und zeigt da noch mal
dieses dieses zögerliche
vorgehen und das es geht natürlich wie
du richtig sagst ein großer Diskrepanz
zu dem was man sagt und das fällt
natürlich einfach auf und macht dann im
politischen Umfeld mit den Partnern
Partnerinnen Europa durchaus erhebliche
Probleme
wir haben hier auch eine Stimme im Chat
die Scholz Strategie gut findet und zwar
sagt er das headphone 96 auf Youtube ich
finde Scholz macht das Gut folgt nicht
den Mainstream und agiert mit Ruhe und
ich finde was mir auch aufgefallen ist
in dieser Antwort von Scholz auf den
letzten Fragensteller da hat er ja noch
mal betont erstens wie viele Waffen
schon geliefert werden was an Artillerie
geliefert wird aber auch ähm was für ein
großes Budget Deutschland zur Hilfe für
die Ukraine frei macht und da hat er ja
noch mal den Sonderposten Deutschlands
betonte die in Europa quasi ich glaube
nach Großbritannien mit vor
Großbritannien so die größten
Summen frei machen ich habe jetzt aber
noch mal angeguckt wie das in der
Relation zur Wirtschaftsleistung oder
das Wirtschaftskraft steht und da
liefert Deutschland der dann
letztendlich gar nicht so viel wie
anteilig andere Länder liefern oder
genauso wenn man sich die Zahlen
anschaut das ist Ihnen doch sehr wichtig
welche Zahlen man sich anschaut wenn man
sich die absoluten Zahlen anschaut steht
Deutschland im Vergleich wirklich gar
nicht so schlecht da wo man natürlich
sagen muss dass die USA deutlich
deutlich mehr liefern schaut man sich
das an und Vergleich zum BIP sind
beispielsweise Länder wie Polen oder
auch baltische Länder deutlich weiter
vorne obwohl sie eben ja sehr klein sind
und wenn wir uns das in der Gesamtschau
anschauen sehen wir dass so gut wie die
oder sogar ein bisschen mehr als die
gesamte Hilfe sowohl militärisch als
auch finanzielle die die Ukraine bekommt
aus den USA bekommt und Europa mit allen
seinen Ländern und Institutionen gerade
meine gegenwirtschaft und wenn wir uns
vergegenwärtigen dass das natürlich ein
Krieg in Europa ist zeigt das auch noch
mal wie wenig eigentlich Europa in der
Lage ist ohne die USA die eigenen
Sicherheitsstrukturen aufrecht zu
erhalten die eigentlich die eigentliche
Sicherheit zu gewährleisten und
vielleicht auch kurz als Kommentar zu
dem Alter zu einem User oder dass der
eine User gerade gesagt hat ich glaube
dass Sch mit dieser Zögerlichkeit bei
vielen Deutschen durchaus auch einen
nervt trifft und die Frage ist eben auch
ist das Kalkül was Scholz genau bei
dieser Politik im letzten Jahr antreibt
vielleicht auch den deutschen nur
häppchenweise mehr Engagement mehr
Lieferung zuzutrauen weil er ihn
befürchtet dass das ein innenpolitischen
backlash geben könnte also es ist
natürlich durchaus eine These der man
folgen kann
ja passend dazu schreibt Facebook Userin
Margarete Marlies von deutschen Boden
sollte doch nie wieder Krieg ausgehen
keine Waffenlieferung ist das ein
Argument was Scholz vielleicht auch noch
umtreibt
jetzt kann ich natürlich auch nicht ganz
genau in den in den Kopf von von Olaf
Scholz oder von seinen beraternen
Beraterinnen
hineinschauen ich glaube allerdings es
gibt ein Problem mit dieser
Argumentation also das ist natürlich die
ganz zentrale Lehre die wir aus der
deutschen Vergangenheit gezogen haben
und aus meiner Sicht auch einer eine
gute aber sie greift in der
Interpretation die viel ja vielleicht in
Deutschland gerade gerade vorherrscht
ein bisschen viel dann ich glaube die
Lehrer aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg sollte
eben nicht nur sein das ist kein Krieg
mehr vom deutschen Boden geben sollte
sondern auch dass Deutschland
Gruppen Länder
schützen sollte die von massiver Gewalt
von massiver militärischer Gewalt auch
von ja ähm
völkerrechtswidrigen kriegen bedroht
sind zu beschützen und dort sein Einsatz
zu zeigen dann sonst heißt das eben auch
dass wir sowas dass wir sowas gewähren
lassen und wenn wir uns in den zweiten
Plastik anschauen dann ist es ja auch
gerade den Ländern damals die
eingegriffen haben also die den
Alliierten zu verdanken dass dieses
Nazi-Regime zu Ende gekommen ist ist
haben die Deutschen irgendwie selber
gemacht und ich glaube das ist eben auch
eine Lehre die wir nicht vergessen
sollten
ich wäre viel grad noch mal im Blick in
die Kommentare wie die Stimmung bei euch
da draußen ist und zwar schreibt über
hat Pocher auf Facebook richtig so keine
Panzerlieferungen in die Ukraine die
Ukraine ist kein Mitglied der NATO und
der EU und auch stören Ungeheuer auf
Youtube schreibt ja ich wäre eher dafür
die Verteidigungsfähigkeit Deutschlands
wieder zu ermöglichen danach kann
geholfen werden bzw
altes Gerät kann ja meinetwegen hin also
hier sprechen sich auch deutlich viele
Menschen gegen Waffenlieferungen aus was
ich mich jetzt noch Frage was wir gerade
sehen ist ja ein Zögern von Olaf Scholz
auf eine Forderung aus der Ukraine auf
die Forderung von Bündnispartnern in
Europa was glaubst du denn auch als
Osteuropa Expertin würde die
Bundesregierung mit Ihrer Unterstützung
vielleicht eher noch mal vorrücken
sollte Russland vielleicht noch mal so
eine Art Mobilisierung bzw eine neue
Offensive ankündigen also wer das ein
Signal was Scholz zum Umdenken bewegen
könnte
also es könnte also ich würde sagen so
einen neue mobilisierungswelle auch noch
eine neue Offensive über die in jedem
Fall den Druck auf die Bundesregierung
erhöhen und zwar aus zwei Gründen also
zum einen würde es natürlich noch mal
die Ukraine militärische Bedrängnis
bringen und nochmal deutlicher machen
wie wichtig auch die militärische
Unterstützung die militärischen
Lieferung für die Ukraine von deutscher
von europäischer von westlicher Seite
sind und zum anderen konnte das
natürlich auch ein Faktor sein der die
öffentliche Meinung in Deutschland auch
noch mal ein bisschen dreht also das ist
jetzt natürlich sehr spekulativ aber wir
sehen ja schon dass die Bilder der
Gewalt des Krieges verständlicherweise
in Einfluss haben darauf wie die
Menschen in Deutschland über diesen
Krieg denken und wie sie bewegt und
welche Unterstützung für die Ukraine die
vielleicht auch für legitim oder
angebracht hat und mir das etwas sehen
könnte es natürlich auch sein das ist
noch mal kleine Schwung in der
öffentlichen Meinung gibt und ich glaube
auch dass das etwas ist auf dass man
Kanzleramt ähm schielt ich würde mir
natürlich aber trotzdem wünschen
wünschen dass
deutsche Außenpolitik und
dementsprechend auch einzeln Instrumente
die man einsetzt wie eben
Waffenlieferung weniger getrieben sind
oder weniger Reaktion sind auf
russisches handeln sondern vor allen
Dingen auch proaktiv reagieren um die ja
um Europa um die europäische
sicherheitsordnung eben auch nach den
eigenen Vorstellungen gestalten zu
können
ich habe hier noch eine Frage aus der
Community
und zwar fragt Sven Odenthal auf
facebook könnte vielleicht auch sein
dass Scholz erst dann Zusagen macht wenn
er weiß dass diese Waffen auch geliefert
werden können es gab ja berichte dass
die Panzer erst 2024 geliefert werden
können kannst du uns dazu sagen
also ich glaube nicht dass das da
ausschlaggebende Punkt ist damals auch
schon wieder gegenteiliges gehört von
rein Metall wenn ich mich recht erinnere
das ist doch schon dieses Jahr möglich
wäre also ich glaube grundsätzlich ist
der Zyklus ja genau andersrum damit die
Industrie Kapazitäten und Material
bereitstellt braucht sie eben aus der
Politik die Sicherheit dass das auch
wirklich gebraucht wird weil wir haben
das im letzten Jahr mit dem Marder
gesehen die Marder wurden dann am krippt
und
für den Kampfeinsatz ausgestattet und
standen dann Monate lang auf einem
Parkplatz rum und das ist natürlich für
Industrieunternehmen ein Risiko und
etwas was man eigentlich ungern macht
das heißt aus meiner Sicht müsste es
genau andersrum folgen die deutsche
Bundesregierung müsste signalisieren wir
wollen das und das liefern die wollen
mit denen den Materialien unterstützen
und die besorgen wir weil das schafft er
die Grundlage dafür dass die Industrie
das dann auch bereitstellt
und ich habe noch eine Frage die so ein
bisschen den
eu-apparat betrifft Olaf Scholz hat ja
an seiner Antwort auch davon gesprochen
dass es der gemeinsame Wille ist der
Europäischen Union alles zu tun damit
die Ukraine frei und unabhängig bleibt
jetzt gab es aber heute Nachmittag eine
Meldung die in der Berichterstattung so
ein bisschen als ungewöhnlich bezeichnet
wurde nämlich dass das EU-Parlament nach
einem Antrag der Grünen Olaf Scholz
aufgefordert hat diese Lieferung von den
Leopard Panzern freizugeben wie
bewertest du das
also das ist ehrlich gesagt etwas was
mich weniger überrascht wir haben über
die letzten Jahre eigentlich immer
wieder gesehen dass gerade das
Europäische Parlament gegenüber Russland
sehr kritisch war und auch in seiner
Einschätzung nicht nur zur russischen
Innenpolitik sondern auch zur russischen
außen und Sicherheitspolitik eigentlich
häufig nicht nur richtig gelegen hat
sondern auch immer ein bisschen ich sag
mal weniger zögerlich war als es
vielleicht die deutsche Bundesregierung
oder auch andere Mitgliedstaaten waren
nicht dass du trotz fällt es natürlich
schon auf dass das Europäische Parlament
so eine eindeutige Aufforderung an ein
einzelnes Land richtet ich glaube aber
am Ende dass das was die Entscheidung im
Bundeskanzleramt hier und
bundesverteilungsministerium zu
Lieferung oder nicht Lieferung von
Leopard 2 Panzern beeinflusst ist dann
eben er die Frage wie groß ist der
wie groß ist der Druck der europäischen
Partner also vor allem Polen des
Baltikums wie groß ist auch ja der Druck
aus den den USA und eben auch der
öffentliche Druck ich glaube das ist das
worauf wir schauen müssen
ja und nachdem wir jetzt einen Blick auf
die Rede von Scholz geworfen haben redet
ja später heute in Davos auch noch der
ukrainische Präsident selenski was
erwartest du dir denn von dieser Rede
also ich glaube selenski wird noch mal
versuchen deutlich zu machen zum einen
wie wichtig und auch zentral die
weltweit und die westliche Unterstützung
für die bisherigen Erfolge noch das
standhalten der Ukraine ist und darauf
Aufbau und dann eben weitere
Unterstützung zu fordern weil da eben
auch weiß dass die militärische die
finanzielle Unterstützung ganz
maßgeblich für den Bestand der Ukraine
ist und wir sehen ja eigentlich dass er
aus meiner Sicht richtigerweise sehr
viel Zeit darin investiert international
zu sprechen international präsent zu
sein weil er natürlich nur durch diese
Präsenz durch durch dieses öffentliche
Reden die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
sichern kann die man zumindest oder als
mindestens braucht
danke dir Sarah dass du dir die Zeit
genommen hast und meine und die Fragen
unserer Community beantwortet hast
vielen dank dir für die Einschätzung
tschüss tschüss ich guck hier noch mal
in den Chat hier sagt Viola Rehm
angegriffene Länder müssen die richtige
Hilfe bekommen um sich wirkungsvoll
wehren zu können und wir haben noch
einen Kommentar von Patrick Meyer von
Youtube der sagt ich finde die
zögerliche Art von Scholz echt schwierig
zu mal letztens noch ein deutscher
general gesagt hat das Schützenpanzer
ohne Kampfpanzer nicht viel Nutzen denn
man braucht beide im Verband vielleicht
zur Info einige Schützenpanzer sind
schon in der Ukraine und es geht bei
Panzern viel um das Zusammenspiel dieser
panzerarten ja das war's für heute mit
ZDF heute live ich denke wenn wir noch
mal auf die Frage vom Anfang gucken
nämlich hat Scholz jetzt nachgegeben
oder gibt Scholz dem Druck europäischer
Partner nach und äußert sich zu den
Panzerlieferungen in die Ukraine können
wir sagen dass das mit dieser Rede in
Davos jetzt noch nicht der Fall waren
wie das Ganze sich weiterentwickelt wir
bleiben auf jeden Fall für euch dran
danke für eure Fragen und Kommentare und
bis zum nächsten Mal wenn ihr mögt
[Musik]